hello and welcome to today's session
part of agilent cell analysis global
conference
my name is bahar easy and i'm sea horse
instrument product specialist
in new england and east canada and with
great pleasure
will be your host for today's seminar
before i
introduce our guest speaker allow me to
share a bit about agilent
and the products within cell analysis
division agilent is a leader in life
sciences has been focused on enabling
our customers to gain
the insights they seek agilent rapidly
growing cell analysis portfolio enables
deeper
more reliable insights across a variety
of cell analysis
applications when the investigators and
drug developers
seek to understand the dynamic cellular
environments and the interactions
this is critically important for
advancing applied translational research
on vaccine development and studying
autoimmune diseases
where a more comprehensive understanding
of host pathogen effects
and mechanism mechanisms of immune
system function
and response is required our
presentation today will
specifically uh speak to how our
solutions are being employed in that
context
with that i'm pleased to welcome dr
heather smallwood
as our guest speaker for today heather
is an assistant professor in department
of pediatrics
and the institute for the study of host
pathogen systems at the university of
tennessee health science center
she is a cell biologist trained in
biochemistry and infectious disease
heather received her phd in biochemistry
and applied
environmental toxicology at washington
state university affiliated with pacific
northwest labs
she did her post doctoral training in
immunology and viral
virology under dr peter dougherty and
paul thomas
at st juice children's research hospital
her current research focuses on defining
the role of metabolism
in respiratory viral infection and its
regulation to identify
meta biomarkers for risk assessment and
therapeutic targeting
before i hand it to heather they remind
you
that there will be a question and answer
period immediately following the talk
and to help us to get as many of your
questions as possible
we encourage you to type in your
questions during the presentation
we will also meet in the networking
lounge at the conclusion of this webinar
to further discuss topics presented
today with additional experts from
the field looking forward to our great
discussions during the q a
and in the networking session with that
i will pass it to you heather the podium
is yours
thank you
thank you for inviting me and
can everyone see my slides
all right uh
can you see my slides all right
i will just as well yes
so thank you for inviting me and um i'm
excited to
tell you a little bit about our work
today
my lab as she mentioned is primarily
focused on
understanding how respiratory viruses
reprogram
cellular metabolism and has metabolism
in order to um
basically be able to find universal
targets our hope is that um
virus by virus we can find targets that
are
changed in terms of controlling host
metabolism and response viral
replication
and then eventually be able to find a
universal target and that is based on
this sort of
general idea that if viruses induce
these metabolic reprogramming we can
actually exploit that
reduce the replication and perhaps
ameliorate disease symptoms or
severity or even prevent them all
together
so i'm going to tell you about this work
in three parts you can see on the bottom
of the slide
a little bit about epithelial
respiratory epithelial cell metabolism
some innate cell metabolic responses and
then some work we're doing in pediatric
patients
so i probably don't need to uh emphasize
too much here
the uh that influenza is a major problem
especially in reference to the current
pandemic
all of you have probably uh have already
had influenza you're perfectly aware of
the symptoms
you may not know how many people it
affects each year uh
five to twenty percent of the population
contracts the flu each year
and
that is particularly a problem for young
and
um and the elderly the young are
generally naive to this
to infection it can hit them harder and
then of course
flu is a particular problem impacting
elderly that might be immune compromised
uh the vaccine is imperfect as we all
know and our current drug therapies
are um that target the virus lead to
resistance and have a very short
treatment window unfortunately influenza
has a
a huge amount of symptom similarity with
copic 19
as you can see here from the list one
distinction
to note my is the change in loss of
taste or smell
and i also just had to put in a word
here that we are certain now that
children are super spreaders of copin 19
that was controversial for a while but
we now know that they are spreaders
and that they contain more viral rna in
their upper respiratory passages
we are currently working to understand
the metabolic responses of cobit 19 but
i don't have enough data to be able to
show you anything reliable on that today
so we're going to focus mainly on the
flu
and other respiratory viruses and and
just know that we are working hard to
determine if the same things are
happening
with the current virus so
if you're not familiar following
influenza infection or viral infection
in general
in the respiratory tract you have a
response
that mediates cell migration from
various compartments in the body to come
in and eliminate the virus and
respiratory tract
and there's a typically different
kinetic curves that occur you can see
these different cell types that we have
this is from a review that we submitted
um and you can just see all these
different cell types have different
kinetics in terms of proliferation and
the little black dots down here
are representing the flu so once we have
a certain number of immune cells present
then we can knock down
the virus and um some of these
cells have been fairly well
characterized in terms of this new field
we call immuno-metabolism and
understanding the
metabolic response of different types of
immune cells
um whereas some are less characterized
but
but at this point the t cells um are
fairly well understood
and and their different metabolic
parameters are
are known and that relates to
this general observations that
clinicians had of observing
flu or flu vaccines induce these
hypermetabolic lesions sometimes in the
lip
in the lymph nodes and they were
detected by pet scan which um
which measures an fdg or glucose analog
uptake in the body
and so at that point this was primarily
attributed to these
proliferating t cells but um some work
i'm going to show you
indicates that epithelial cells can
contribute as well
and it's just a reminder respiratory
epithelial cells far outnumber immune
cells of course in the respiratory tract
and there are many many cells in the
respiratory tract that i'm not going to
cover today
um this figure is taken from a review
you can see the reference down the lower
right hand corner
the first half of my talk i'll probably
go over fairly quickly
because this data is published in orange
here and it was published in in 2017.
but in this um first body first part of
the talk i'm primarily focused on these
ciliated respiratory epithelial cells
and respiratory epithelial cells in
general
and their metabolic response to
influenza infection and we'll touch a
little bit more
later on some of the responses that we
see with other immune cells
in this area and we're also interested
in my lab and understanding how the
metabolite gradient has changed
following infection and that's um
that's going to be present in this
pericellular liquid that i
that i underlined over here i think i
may mention a little bit about glucose
um
transport in there but we won't go into
that
into too great detail there so
respiratory cells far outnumber immune
cells
and when we looked at immune compromised
children that had respiratory viral
infections
indeed we found that they had high
levels of glucose uptake in their lungs
um are what is referred to as
hyper metabolic regions in a pet scan
so the top graphs that you see on the
y-axis you see this
positive and red the positive for
glucose uptake
and then across the x-axis we see days
and we found that there was a
significant correlation between
the pcr positive diagnosis with uh
respiratory viral infection
and the positive rate of
hyper-glycolytic lesions in the lungs
so in v here below you see these ct
scans
the top row is of
the patient following a clearance of
influenza infection so that's several
months later
you can see that the ct scan is quite
healthy the gray
there on the lungs and um
below that you see these ground glass
opacities you may have been
hearing about um lately this is also
something that um we've
defined and with covet 19 and so people
have been discussing this the sort of um
consolidation and opacity in the lungs
the same thing
we find here with influenza now moving
over you see in the pet scan you see
these dark blotches this is where we
have an increase in fdg
uptake or glucose uptake in the lungs
and then when you look at the overlay
you can really
see these hot spots of of metabolic
activity
following influenza infection so
since these kids largely were leukopenic
and many immune compromised
and we thought that this might not just
be mediated by
t-cell proliferation or proliferation of
immune cells
in the lungs so we went ahead and we
performed proteomics on
normal human bronchial epithelial cells
taken from child donors
and infected them for 17 hours with a
strain that's circulated in the 2009
pandemic the california 04 strain
and what we found in these proteomics
was that by and large over here in
yellow and a you can see
that metabolic pathways were
significantly enriched
and surprisingly really dominated the
enrichment pathways that we had
following 17 hours following influenza
infection
and the chord graph on the right just
shows you that there's a significant
amount of overlap between a lot of the
proteins that we identified
in these different pathways and in their
function within the different pathways
so we felt like the the response of the
respiratory epithelial cells fairly
early on at 17 hours after
um possibly uh one um replication cycle
maybe two
is um is very robust
so then we moved on and we performed um
some seahorse assays
and um i'm i'll talk a little bit more
in detail
about some of the these particular
assays later
but um in this first slide i'm just
going to introduce that what we were
looking at here is just the
extracellular acidification rate as a
proxy for lactate production and the
glycolytic pathway
and what we found was following
influenza infection here in this black
bar
it was very significantly increased over
uninfected controls in the white bar
now we were also interested in
understanding if this was just a
response
of the epithelial cells to um
activation so we used poly ic and r848
which are both
similar to to stimulate a
viral infection as an rna virus and then
we also used lps
we also inactivated the virus so that it
could not replicate within the
epithelial cells to determine if the
metabolic response we were seeing
was in fact impacted by viral
replication
so in the bpl lps and poly ic and r848
you see
that they do in most cases
increase glycolysis with these
treatments
but they are significantly diminished
compared to the viral
the viral infection and
then we also used oxygen consumption
rates as
a proxy for mitochondrial respiration
and
as you can see here we have a
significant increase
in mitochondrial respiration or oxygen
consumption
following influenza infection or
treatment with any of these other
treatments
now um in panel c we were looking at the
proton production rate which we
this this paper is quite old so we
typically don't publish this anymore but
um it mirrors what we found in
in the glycolysis and penalty over in d
you see that following influenza
infection we have a significant increase
in glucose uptake
indicating that these cells are bringing
in a very significant amount of glucose
from the media and um
this is also significantly higher than
any of the other
treatments that we that we use
and one of the uh first players that we
looked at well not the first one of the
first players that we
came to look at following
curating all of the proteomic data was
a transcription factor known as cmec and
so if you're familiar with metabolism
cmic is sort of referred to as this
master regulator of tumor metabolism and
cancer metabolism it's also
implicated in some immune
immune immunometabolism and we found
that following influenza infection there
was this transient increase in semic
um we could use a stemic inhibitor
and as you can see in black this
dose-dependent decrease in either the
glycolysis or oxygen consumption for
respiration
with the addition of the cemic inhibitor
following influenza infection
and importantly over an age is
what we refer to as glutamine and
glucose addiction
so uh commonly in scenic mediated tumors
and and some cancers they become very
dependent upon
uh increasing their glucose and
glutamine consumption to fuel metabolism
for a cell replication
and if you deplete it's known that if
you deplete either of these substrates
from the medium
these cancer cells typically
[Music]
die and what we found was following
influenza infection
um the normal human bronchial epithelial
cells were also glucose and glutamine
addicted so on the far right you see
when we strip when we restrict both
glucose and glutamine
um we have a very significant reduction
in viability only in the presence of
influenza infection
and this is again in keeping with uh uh
several other observations in uh
semi-mediated tumors
so with our proteomic data and some
of this information that we had
indicating these metabolic changes um
we set about to do a metabolic drug
targeted
screen for influenza infection in this
case because we had so many similarities
between semic um
tumors we used a medulloblastoma
drug screen that was being performed at
st jude on tumor xenographs
and i adapted it to influenza screening
and look to see what drugs would reduce
viral titer
now all of these data as i mentioned
before is previously
published in the first part of this talk
so i'm kind of going it over over it
quickly
um it's a as i mentioned uh or showed
before in cell reports in 2017
this particular piece is not published
um and all
it's showing you is that we had a
significant bias
in our uh drugs and our drug
target hits and what i thought might be
of interest to this group if you're
interested in understanding
viral metabolism is that depending upon
whether we prophylactically treat with a
drug
or therapeutically treat with a drug we
will in fact
have different drug targets that are um
that are
uh are found sorry i'm trying to change
the presentation
so moving on um
one of the drugs that we found uh was
this pi3k inventory inhibitor bez235
this drug was able to restore some of
the signaling events
as you can see here from the pi3k mtor
pathway
these areas indicate the different
phosphorylation events that
are um blocked that are induced by the
virus and then blocked by bez235
in panel b you can see that cemic
expression was significantly
reduced with the use of bez235 in the
context of viral infection
and in c you can see that unlike other
pi3k
inhibitors that have been shown
applications against influenza infection
um the imgene production the viral
ending production
stayed constant irrespective of baz
treatment indicating that this
drug was simply not not just blocking um
an entry
uh pathway of uh for the virus
but because the engine was still capable
of replicating
but it has some sort of downstream
effect and when we treated with this
drug again we saw
that the glycolysis um
increased with influenza infection in
black and then when we use this drug to
treat and
red solid bars we saw a significant
decrease in um
not only the glycolytic capacity of the
cells the ability of them to run
atp production on glycolysis but also in
in glycolysis in general um which here
is referred to as the glucose-induced
response because we've added a little
bit of glucose to the medium
and the glycolytic stress test which i'm
going to cover in just a minute in
detail
so you see here that this bez235
was able to restore the glycolytic
capacity of these cells to
non-infected levels when we took this
treatment in vivo we started
48 hours prior to infection and followed
for another five days for
a total of seven days uh with an
oral gavage of vz235
we found that there really was no
difference between the
vehicle and the infected um
mice however we had a significant
survival benefit that was conveyed
following the ez235 treatment here in
red
so you see this very significant
increase in survival
whereas the black group was at about a
15 survival rate we bumped it up to
almost 60
survival with this treatment then um
complementing that and probably um
what's leading to this survival benefit
is a reduction in viral titer as you can
see in d
and an increase in the overall
breathing parameters by plantasmography
and the ability what i like to say is
decreased respiratory
distress in the mice following a
treatment with bez235
so what i think you can see here
um is that the
or what i've tried to convince you of
anyway is that influenza induces changes
in epithelial cell metabolism this
happens independent of immune cells
immune cells aren't necessary because
these
these experiments were performed in
vitro on primary human epithelial cells
in isolation
and um a lot of the metabolic response
that we're seeing
of these epithelial cells is indicative
of sort of parasitization
of epithelial cells where they are
reprogrammed and lose control of their
metabolism as is evident by their
inability to shift their metabolic
program
when glucose and glutamine are
restricted
and this metabolic program is essential
for
viral replication and that makes sense
because
the epithelial cells are the primary
compartment where
the virus is replicating and of course
before a virus can bud it requires a
substantial amount of
biomass primarily proteins and and
lipids
and this drives a sort of metabolic
phenotype that
is similar to some of the
some cancers where you see this
sort of increase in carbon flexibility
utilization to
and carbon commitment into
macromolecules
for producing things like proteins and
rna
so now i'm going to slow down a little
bit because i'd like to tell you
about our work in
dendritic cells and so
um the difference between
there's many differences between
respiratory epithelial cells and
dendritic cells but for the purpose of
this talk one of the interesting
components that we're looking at is that
dendritic cells when they're
infected or taking on influenza the
influenza is still present
and there's some genome replication
but the viruses are not budding it's
what we call an abortive infection so
the the dc's are not actually producing
um virus like the epithelial cells are
um and there's a substantial amount of
literature indicating that dc's
do have a metabolic response to tlr
stimulate stimulation so
we were curious on as to whether the
dendritic cells would have the same
sort of parasitized epithelial metabolic
response that we saw or if they would
have
a metabolic response similar to tlr
stimulation or
a response unique to flu and these data
are currently available
in pre-print and biorx and accepted to
plus pathogens
should be out this month
so as i mentioned before
there has been a substantial amount
published on
dendritic cell metabolism with lps
stimulation and tlr
agonist treatments indicating that they
have this
characteristic increase in glycolysis
and decrease or defect in mitochondrial
respiration following activation
and a lot of this work has been very
eloquently done by the pierces
um here i'm just highlighting a review
by ed pierce um and they have
extensively used the seahorse instrument
to really be able to characterize these
pathways
i'm sorry this response in dendritic
cells and we are sticking with a model
system for dendritic cells
of bone marrow derived and feature
differentiated dcs from mice and we're
infecting them with a mouse-adapted
strain of influenza at the same time
point as we did the epithelial cells and
when we did proteomics on these cells
on the dendritic cells we found a very
similar program
as you can see from the pie charts to
what we had previously found in the
epithelial cells
that is we had a very large increase in
this
significant enrichment in metabolic
pathways that were changing either up
regulated in red on the top or down
regulated in blue
following influenza infection when we
separated this
into the soluble and insoluble fraction
we wanted to understand how metabolic
proteins were moving back and forth
between these compartments because not
only their abundance but also their
location control some of their activity
and we see here in this very large
circle up top and red
you can see that all of these proteins
involved in carbohydrate metabolism
are highly increased
in our upregulated in our insulin in our
fractions following influenza infection
so um we also wanted to look with the
dendritic cells at flux
so we used some traditional measures
where we had different substrates that
were labeled
and we fed them to the dendritic cells
and watched their uh metabolism of these
different substrates
and followed the products to determine
um if in fact we could pinpoint some of
the pathways involved
so we have the a
here and glycol we have an increase in
glycolysis as
as we would expect um significantly
increases following
influenza infection not much happening
in the pentose phosphate pathway and b
with a slight decrease in the tca cycle
in c and a
slight increase in glutamine olysis
indeed with not too much going on in
terms of our
fatty acid beta oxidation
so we wanted to look closer at this and
because dendritic cells are so
responsive to the tlr in
our agnes of course we wanted to go back
to our c-tourist assay where we could be
able to look at multiple parameters
simultaneously
looking at all of the our favorite tlr
agonists that simulate the flu or lps
as well as our bpl and activated and
this was really a great platform to
allow us to be able to do
live kinetic measurements and um the
seahorse can be a little bit complex
and uh equations somewhat complicated if
you're not used to it
um but i kind of like to just drill it
down and
my preference is to sort of try and
simplify
these types of things as much as
possible so people don't glaze over when
we're talking about metabolism
and um with the sea horse for glycolysis
you can really
basically just think about that in terms
of the stoichiometry of
how much glucose is coming in and how
much lactate is being produced so if
you're measuring this extracellular
acidification and you know the
stoichiometry of this is one to one then
you can really
be looking at and measuring this in real
time
what's happening to glucose in terms of
glycolysis likewise
um you can look at your oxygen
consumption rates based on oxidative
phosphorus correlation on the far
right and come to
a proxy for what's happening in terms of
mitochondrial respiration
particularly in a combination of using
some of these
very well known inhibitors of different
complexes
in the electron transport chain and
um so these are these are some of the
assays that i'm going to tell you about
in a moment
but i would just uh like to remind you
that we're really just talking about
um math that is done on on a program
after we apply all these
when we're looking at just extracellular
acidification as a proxy for glycolysis
as well as oxygen consumption for
mitochondrial respiration
and what we found uh was not surprising
in terms
of glycolysis so um in a
you can see our data where we have the
um uh control
in white and then in black we have
the influenza infection as well as our
bpl inactivated
poly scr848 and so on and we have this
very characteristic response and what's
called the
glycolytic stress test where we add
glucose and then we measure glycolysis
and then we inhibit atp synthase with
oligomyosin
and look to see how much the cells can
operate entirely on glycolysis for atp
production and then we'll add 2gg to
sort of inhibit everything and bring it
down
and allow us to measure that
acidification in the absence of these
processes
and so you see over here under the under
a
that our glycolysis was significantly
increased irrespective of
the agonist or the activation level
um of the virus so in both replicating
and non-replicating virus we have
significant increase in glycolysis
as well as all of our tlr agonists um
we see that the glycolytic capacity for
the most part was significantly
increased and only in the case of
influenza infection and lps do we have a
real increase in our
non-glycolytic acidification below that
we went and we looked at the glucose
uptake just to determine
how much glucose that dendritic cells
were taking in
following influenza infection and these
other treatments
and again we saw an increase in glucose
uptake
17 hours after influenza infection or
treatment with lps
[Music]
where it got really interesting was the
response in terms of respiration
so we've used oligomyosin i mentioned
before to inhibit atp synthase and that
allows us to be able to then calculate
the atp production you can see in the
pink box
you can use fccp to
uncouple your proton transport and then
sort of ramp up the system to see what
your maximal
respiration is and how the system can
work um
uninhibited and then we use a
combination of this anthropomorphic
known and that's going to inhibit
everything and bring it down so that you
can calculate the non-mitochondrial
oxygen consumption and for cells like
macrophages and dendritic cells
or when you're working with viruses this
is particularly important because
a lot of these cells are going to have a
sort of reactive oxygen burst and at
dpas oxygenases and other things um
ionos other things that are going to
produce radicals and
oxygen species and that's gonna that's
going to throw those measurements off so
you really need something like the
mitochondrial stress stress where you
can
remove that oxygen consumption that
might confound your measures
so at the top here you see that basal
respiration was significantly increased
following influenza infection and this
was
different significantly different than
what we saw
with either poly ic r848 or lps all of
the tlr stimulations were significantly
lower respiration following following
treatment
with the dendritic cells and distinct
from
influenza only the inactivated virus
was was similar to the flu
then when we looked at the atp
production you can clearly see
that um there's there's this um
impairment
with r848 and lps and this as i
mentioned before
um was um found previously uh
and had lp the lps response where
it does not respond to fccp is uh as a
sort of characteristic
response of the dendritic cells and and
indicating that
um they are um uncoupled or the
respiration is at the very least um
some of the different complexes are not
responding and
um that mitochondrial respiration is
is not functioning properly and you can
see that across the board on all of
these measures
where r848 and lps these tlr agonists
respond similarly in the mitochondrial
stress test
and as opposed to what we see with the
flu
either the inactivated or the activated
virus and i i sort of boil these down to
when you're looking at your mass
maximal respiration as what's your limit
what how
how high can you go and then your spare
respiratory capacity um when i get toxic
just talked about
this being how close to the limit you
are operating when we come in before we
before we start so what's the difference
between your basal and your max
and then um these two measures also give
us a little glimpse into how healthy
we could say if you want to
anthropomorphize the mitochondria
are how well the respiration is running
and we see that in the case of
both lp and both l measures lps is as
significantly different than
the controls and with the flu in the
case of the the proton leak as well
and if you are familiar with other
measures than this type of bioenergetics
then
you can kind of think of the coupling
officially efficiency as a sort of po
surrogate for the po ratio so
it was very interesting to us because we
were anticipating and that we may find
uh the medical the mitochondrial
respiratory
response of dendritic cells to flu was
similar to
lps and in fact what we found was that
poly ic
and flu were very different from
r848 or lps stimulation
then you can use a little bit of math uh
understanding of buffering capacity
and use the same inhibitors um and then
calculate the amount of um the rate my
atp rate uh using a sort of ratio
and looking at your oxygen consumption
and your exercise acidification
and what you see here um on the right
from this atp rate assay is
the mitochondrial atp production on the
y-axis
and the glycolytic atp production on the
x-axis and it gives us a very nice just
kind of global overview where you can
see that
what's clustering together are the
mitochondrially impaired
rh48 and lps treatments and the um
the viral and the virus irrespective of
inactivation so
then when we come down um to the bar
graphs below
we're basically just um using we use the
wave software as everyone does to
calculate the
these measures and account for the
buffering capacity and
what you see is that um we have a very
high rate glycolytic atp production rate
um following influenza and particularly
in comparison
to our other treatments and you can see
just by
the order of magnitude on the y-axis
that we are heavily dependent upon the
glycolytic atp as opposed to
mitochondrial
and atp production um overall
and that the only treatment that
actually increased this
was the
influenza irrespective of inactivation
so there's another assay that seahorse
has developed i think we're going to hit
them all probably in this talk but
and that is the flex fuel assay uh and i
am going to talk about this a little bit
differently than how
is often viewed um and that's largely
because what i was interested in
understanding
was not the preference of the
dendritic cells for a single substrate
but their ability to work with
different substrates and to move back
and forth from the substrates
based on our observation
that i'll talk about in a minute uh
regarding their
their capacity for using glucose and
glutamine
and um it's essentially similar to
what we've been looking at in terms of
monitoring the oxygen consumption rate
as you can see here underneath this
little
green bean mitochondria um
which are good we're also going to add
different inhibitors
to stop different substrate from coming
in and
and then attempt to answer the question
what is the
capacity for the cells
to run entirely on a specific substrate
or their dependency
on a substrate so i kind of i kind of
equate it to
the ability of a person to be able to
survive
entirely on hamburgers or entirely
without hamburgers
um i i know which i would prefer but
anyway um
so your capacity um
versus your dependency with the
dendritic cells there was not really a
whole lot of dependency on
any particular substrate following
influenza infection
but the capacity slightly increased
for their ability to use any of the
substrates whether it was fatty acid
glutamine or pyruvate
to fuel the fuel metabolism
and and then that basically that
calculation
allows you to you can calculate from
those two numbers the
overall flexibility of the cells which
was slightly increased
but i prefer to look at the capacity and
dependency but
definitely we can say that influenza
infection changes the plasticity of the
dendritic cells in terms of their
preference for mitochondrial substrates
now unlike
the nhbs which you can see in h here
which i showed you before
which had this dramatic 50 loss in
viability following influenza infection
and restriction of glutamine and glucose
you see
that the dendritic cells over on the
left
do not have that same phenotype
and they remain viable irrespective of
restricting
glucose and glutamine and
we believe that is through differences
that
this that the dendritic cells have in
terms of controlling their pi3k
mtor pathway and some other pathways
involved here where
they do not actually turn on the same
metabolic pathways and responses
to um to flu that the
normal human bronchial epithelial cells
do and we're still
exploring some of that area however they
do have
this increase in stemic this increases
later it occurs at four hours
but we do have a transient increase in
cement with it in the dendritic cells
and once again when we use our
semiconductor and orange here you can
see that we have a loss
of the um glycolysis and mitochondrial
respiration
those are the basal levels measured from
the glycolytic stress test and the
mitochondrial stress
so what we wanted to know then was if we
inhibited these different substrates or
cement did it have a functional impact
on the dendritic cells
and what we found was in the top panel
that inhibiting cmic
really inhibited the migratory capacity
of the infected dendritic cells
so we just looked at their ability to
migrate into this region a following
influenza infection which is
significantly increased
with infection and then when you applied
a
mic inhibitor it was brought back down
to normal levels and when you inhibited
other mitochondrial substrates
it did have some effect but not to the
levels of what we saw
with cmec we also used a
seahorse t-cell activation assay and
that's basically just
working off the understanding that
t-cells have this rapid
increase in glycolysis following
activation and you can stimulate them
and
look at um at that response immediately
which was important for us because what
we were interested in
and looking at was the transfer of
inhibiting something in a dendritic cell
how did it transfer to
t cells if we looked at that at a long
term
say 72 hours or further out
we would lose the ability to have that
pathway inhibited in the dendritic cells
and it no longer would translate and we
did do time courses on that
um into the responses for the t cell so
we were really interested in this assay
because it allowed us to be able to do
something and
very very rapidly assess it and what we
found was that
the response of the t cells
to dendritic cells that had different
pathways inhibited but were
infected so they should be capable of
priming the t cells
um were dramatically different depending
upon whether
the pathways were inhibited
whether that be um glutamine and green
and utilization fatty acid and blue or
pyruvate in red or when we blocked
semic or glycolysis um
in orange we went through then
and looked at the populations and how
this affected the populations of t
cells and i don't have time to go over
this because i want to have plenty of
time for q a but basically we used
an ot1 system where we infected with a
virus
that was very specific for these ot-1t
cells that had an oval albumin peptide
and then we looked
at what happened when we challenged them
with dendritic cells that were infected
with that
virus in the context of different
inhibitors in the dendritic cells
and we found that indeed we had a
significant loss of different t
cell populations when some
of the inhibitors were used as well as
the vez235 inhibitor
and i didn't mention this previously but
after our work in
mice the bez235 has since been shown to
significantly reduce
respiratory viral infections in the
elderly and so
we're really interested in understanding
how that response is different
between its ability to inhibit what i
showed you originally in the epithelial
cells
versus what it seems to be doing in our
dendritic cells um
and how it may be dampening some
aberrant immune responses there
we went in vivo and just made sure that
what we had seen
in our in vitro systems were
recapitulated so we removed
these highly inflammatory type dc's from
the lungs of mice
nine days following influenza infection
we did the proteomics as you can see
here
it's very similar to what we found in
vitro
as i mentioned before we were asked to
do it with multiple viruses we tried
three different influenza strains it all
recapitulated what we were finding
um and then what's important here to
note
is that when we compared the glycolytic
versus tca cycle proteins
um an expression of
these enzymes from the dendritic cells
that were bone marrow derived in b
or tip dc's from the lung and c
we found that they really recapitulated
each other well and we have this highly
glycolytic phenotype
in the dendritic cells um irrespective
of whether they are coming from an
alveolar infection or an in vitro
infection
and um the uh tca cycle is not
ameliorated as we've seen before it
appears to be this sort of non-canonical
and
low functioning
pathway but it is significantly less
than what we see in glycolysis
so it looks like uh in our dendritic
cells
at any rate we the metabolic response
that we're seeing
to dendritic cells is really more of
their
activation and what's interesting about
it is that it's unique
in comparison to what we see with lps um
and it's unique in paris in comparison
to what we see with r848
we saw a much more similar phenotype
with the
inactivated virus which makes sense
since they don't replicate ndcs
and it was similar to what we found with
poly ic comparatively speaking
and so we think that what's happening in
dendritic cells as others have
postulated is their metabolic response
is occurring as a part of activation
however this activation uh at least in
the case of influenza is
is distinct from other agonists
so i don't have a whole lot of time so i
will tell you that this is summarized
some of this work is summarized in a
review that we recently
published in immunological reviews where
we sort of compare what we found in
epithelial cells and in the dendritic
cells um
and basically what the overall takeaway
is that
um these um epithelial cells are slaves
to the virus they're glutamine and
glucose addicted they don't have a lot
of control the dendritic cells appear to
have this metabolic plasticity they can
toggle back and
forth between different substrates even
in the context of
activation from the virus this makes
sense they have to move through nutrient
deplete regions
they have to go through
nutrient-depleted areas such as a
tightly packed lymph node move through
the circulatory system which may be
rich and then move into territories such
as
an infected lung which will have a foci
and that we have uh believe will be uh
nutrient deplete
similar to a tumor because the
epithelial cells are taking up so much
glucose and glutamine we don't have time
to show you the data that we're working
on um
to prove that right now because i wanted
to get to a little bit of clinical data
and um that clinical data is just a sort
of a little
uh work that we just published in the
clinical or i'm sorry that was just
accepted in a clinical report
and that's where we are looking at
similar
metabolic changes in respiratory viral
infections in this case we're looking at
uh respiratory system virus
and our general question was these
viruses are different a virologist will
tell you that these
are very different viruses but the
symptoms are very similar and we wanted
to know if we would get the same
sort of bioenergetic profile from
clinical samples and with rsv infection
as what we found with the flu rsv
again induces very similar symptoms
children get it there's no known
treatment
and i believe it's by the time of six or
seven years old
virtually 100 penetrants in the
population of children
it can be very very dangerous for for
some children
um again we saw these hyper metabolic
lesions in children with rsv
infection um via pet scan where we have
this
these ground glass opacities and the ct
scan and the pet scans showing a really
high
level of fdg concentration and uptake in
the
in the kids lungs unique to rsp what we
found was that rsb
tends to linger in terms of the
hypermetabolism we appear to have this
um a significant
increase if you get if you look in the
graph on the right
uh in terms of um the um
the pet scan positivity rate and the
days it's very different from any of
the patterns that we find in in the
other
viral infections that we study
indicating that the rsv is inducing that
hyper metabolism
longer so we did a pilot study we had
six children
we had three con we originally had three
controls and three rsv infected children
and um one of the controls ended up
being positive when we did the pcr
so we ended up with four rsv infected
children and compared them to
um two controls we did um nasopharyngeal
rinses of these children to pull out the
cells
and the metabolites out of their upper
airways during infection
we performed mass spectrometry again in
this case metabolomics looking to see
if there were changes in the metabolite
pattern
within the upper airways and what we
found was that there were some
significant differences
in common uh and lactate for example and
other
metabolic metabolites that one would
expect based on our
previous studies and some of our in
vitro data when we looked at cells so
these cells are
from children um upper respiratory tract
and we put them on
the excess except the 96 and did the
seahorse assay
we did both the glycolytic stress test
as well as the um
as well as the uh mitochondrial stress
test and you can see
quite clearly that uh rsv
infection significantly increases
glycolysis and the other parameters that
we found similar to influenza
and these um these samples taken from
children
are displaying the similar patterns in
terms of mitochondrial respiration
if not higher mitochondrial respiration
than what we found before
we also did single cell transcriptomics
we're still working on
on some of that but basically
unfortunately these data came from
cryopreserved cells we weren't able to
do everything in one day
and what we found was we weren't able to
recapitulate some of the pathways that
we had anticipated
in terms of um the metabolic response so
the take home from that
is if you're taking respiratory
epithelial cells out of children from
the upper airways
you should process and use those samples
quickly if you're
intending on monitoring metabolism
we did see quite a few changes obviously
we were able to capture
all of the immune compartment the
respiratory epithelial cells don't make
it through a crowd preservation in these
types of samples
but we were able to look at the immune
cells um
and we were able to get profiles of them
but we did not we do not believe that
the
metabolic responses that we saw were
indicative of
what we would find in a fresh sample so
we're repeating those experiments
so indeed rsv induces similar glycolytic
and
mitochondrial bioenergetics is what we
found in vitro in the flu
and and previously in general
um so we think this may be a sort of
broad response
to uh respiratory viruses as i said
before we're looking in
sarcov2 right now um i'll just conclude
with basically
we find these respiratory virus viral
infections increasing metabolism in the
lungs as well as in these upper
respiratory samples
it seems like we can modulate it it
appears to be cell specific with the
modulation in terms of whether we use
vez
235 on epithelial cells
or innate cells they have very different
responses to the drug and
because there are inherent differences
in pathways
these two cells have inherent different
inherently different responses
and abilities to control their
metabolism in the face of influenza
infection
and we are currently exploring how
neighboring cells
impact that and how they impacts that
i just like to acknowledge my lab uh we
are hiring
and um these are the ladies that have
done all of this work
um and some of the other people working
with me on
various studies so
with that i'd be happy to take any
questions
thanks heather fantastic presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please submit it
we'll be able to get to a couple
questions before the end of
our however even if we don't make it to
your question we'll be
forwarding all of them to our speaker
and the agilent team to follow up with
you
let's get started and the first question
that we received um heather
is do you think that the lack of
effective viral resolution
or increased risk in patients with
metabolic diseases such as obesity or
diabetic patient
for flu or covet could be related
to an altered metabolic flexibility in
denderic cells acting as apc that
reduces cell activation
so i think that there's a lot of
there's a lot of work to be done so i
i'm not an obesity researcher i am
dabbling currently in looking at some of
that
but also let me just say i can't
actually see the questions and i wasn't
able to see them during my talk so i'm
going to try and go back
uh yeah i still i still can't see
question number one but
um but yeah i think that um certainly
the especially with well let's go with
diabetics because i think that's a
simpler case
um there is a lot of argument to be made
for the amount of glucose
impacting and perhaps hyper driving
some immune response to something like
influenza
in the upper airways just based on the
knowledge that we have so much higher
glucose levels
in that fluid that i discussed that i
wouldn't be able to cover
at the beginning and an imbalance
in the metabolite gradient the trans
epithelial metabolite gradient
and an imbalance in high levels of
glucose i think
in in the lungs in general are
going to increase your disease pathology
probably through not just dendritic cell
antigen presentation but through
amplifying all the way through from the
innate to the adaptive response
as well as probably leading to a higher
level of viral replication
so not only are the metabolites feeding
a higher level of virus probably in that
area
they're also feeding a higher level of
immunopathology perfect
i'm going to combine two questions um
for next one
um and i'm hoping that we can get to
both
um did you check the proteomics and the
genomics pattern
after viral infection and
have you considered using seahorse for
low throughput compound screening
to orthogonally confirm your proteomics
results you've shown it for
both epithelial cells and denderic cells
um so we have not
used the sea horse for confirming
the proteomics that's what you just
asked me yeah
i mean beyond the pathway analysis right
so
we knew beyond a general view
so in general from the proteomics we saw
this um sort of characteristic warburg
like
metabolism which is of course you can
capture in the seahorse
but in terms of specific targets no
well it was just a broad overview does
that answer your question
yes it did but do you envision seahorse
to be useful
in that direction where i find it
intriguingly useful for my work is that
what we were able to see in terms of our
drug responses
the drug response that the response
seems to be that the drugs that
we found now i have to preface this with
i only took
three of the of the main drugs in vivo
um but the successful seahorse drug was
also the successful drug in vivo
oh okay good too metabolic targeting
drugs
the drug that uh restored our metabolic
program in the sea horse was also the
drug that responded
and in vivo now whether that's just you
know
luck i don't know yet um
going back to the first part of the
question um were you able to do any
genomics or
i mean you've shown some of your
proteomics data upon infection
uh but was there any correlation between
the genomics and proteomics data
so are you talking about the
transcriptomics in the tip disease
versus the
proteomics yes i mean
one of our audiences question but i'm
assuming that's yes
um so we
we have looked at that and um i if
you're asking me
if i have uh looked at
sort of a one by one to see how well
is the expression uh translating to the
protein
no i have not done a within group
comparison we use the transcriptomics on
the tip dc's
primarily because obviously in vivo we
get much less so we're not going to be
able to do the proteomics that we could
do
with our model systems however you could
see
from the the graph that i showed
that in general when we were looking at
the changes of the
proteins or the transcripts um they were
trending in the same direction so
the transcripts um for the tftcs that
for glycolysis were significantly higher
than
tca cycle as well as the proteins that
we saw in the bone marrow derived dc's
glycolysis is significantly higher than
tca cycle
fantastic next question
is there have been a repeated reports
suggestion
suggesting virus induced mitochondrial
dysfunction
is there any implication of flu-caused
mitochondrial dysfunction
in increased glycolytic energy
production
for flu infected epithelial cells in
contrast
to tlr activation by the agonist
or inactivated virus
so um i think
i don't know whether they're
specifically talking there are flu so
flu technically one of the reasons for
using flu in this particular work
um aside from the fact that i'm very
interested in influenza is that
it's it's excellent because it doesn't
have a lot of genetic genetic components
other viruses like cmd there are other
viruses that carry known
metabolic regulators known proteins that
are going to be involved in them
flu does have a um it doesn't code for
a protein that localizes the
mitochondria and is thought to have some
some um activity there um
in terms of the epithelial uh response
um the the data that i showed with the
uh i'm sorry i'm looking at it over on
the screen the data that i showed with
the
um the uh epithelial cells
following infection would indicate that
the their uh
oxygen consumption rate respiration is
still functional
so um i
i at least at 17 hours
in this system i i don't see an evidence
that
it's destroyed i would anticipate
however
at longer time points that is what part
of what's mediating epithelial
death because of course uh after so long
they can only keep up this crazy
metabolic program for so long right
they're going to die
and um they can't continue to bleb off
their membranes and keep
producing for the virus forever and so i
would assume that
at a later time point if i were guessing
you wouldn't encounter that
awesome um i wanted to um wrap it up
um at this point because we are the top
of the hour but please join us
during the networking event you can
access it
via the link when you close this webinar
and also there is a direct link on the
main
platform for the lab roots event
um there we will continue the
conversation and
and share more questions from the field
with you
thank you heather for sharing your work
with us and
i would like to conclude the meeting